Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Rose, comradeship, fair play. Those are the words, Dominic, with which the Frenchman Jorimé in 1928 persuaded his colleagues on the Fédération Internationale de Football Association, FIFA. Beautiful French, Tom. Beautiful French. To set up a World Cup. And the legacy of that move is very much with us today, is it not? Because it's a week before the start of the World Cup in Qatar.
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。尊严、同仁情谊、公平竞争。多米尼克，正是这几个词，让法国人儒勒·雷米特（Jules Rimet）于1928年说服了他在国际足联（FIFA）的同僚们——法语真优美，汤姆。法语真优美——去创办一届世界杯。而这一举措的遗产至今仍与我们同在，不是吗？因为距离卡塔尔世界杯开幕正好还有一周。
Yes, it is. 32 teams will be taking part. And one of the things that strikes me about the involvement of Rime setting up this massive global juggernaut is it's very like the Olympics. There seem to be kind of Frenchmen appropriating British ideals of fair play
是的，确实如此。将有32支球队参赛。关于雷米特建立这个庞大全球巨无霸的经历，最触动我的一点是，它非常像奥运会。似乎总有一种法国人在挪用英国人的公平竞争理想，
and kind of marketing them to the world. And as with the Olympics, we did two episodes on the modern Olympics, didn't we? And it began with our memorable account of Dwyle flunking. If you haven't heard that, do check that out. One of the great moments on the podcast, I think. And we said at the beginning of that, you know, I think that there are two areas of historical inquiry that lots and lots of people who otherwise are obsessed by history can say they're very proud to know nothing about one of them is religion and one of them is sport
并将其向全球推广。就像奥运会一样，我们之前做了两期关于现代奥运会的节目，不是吗？而那是以我们对“掷牛膀骨游戏”（Dwyle flunking）的难忘介绍开篇的。如果你还没听过，一定要去听听。我认为那是本播客的高光时刻之一。我们在那一期的开头就说过，你知道，我认为历史研究中有两个领域，许多原本对历史极其痴迷的人，却会自豪地宣称自己对此一无所知——其中之一是宗教，另一个就是体育。
yeah i think that's absolutely right so in fact a lot of people who regularly listen to this podcast when we said we are intending to do the definitive history of the world cup they sort of there are some people who reacted with horror. Oh no, not football in a history podcast. But football is a brilliant window, Tom. Well, so football, I would say, I mean, it's the single most popular activity that's ever been known by humanity. I mean, it's followed by more people than any other leisure activity that we've ever had. So that in itself makes it of incredible interest.
是的，我觉得完全正确。事实上，当我们在节目里说“我们打算做一期关于世界杯的决定性历史”时，许多经常收听这本播客的听迷们，他们的反应可以说是充满了惊恐。“噢，不，可别在历史播客里谈足球。”但汤姆，足球是一个绝佳的窗口。嗯，所以如果要我说的话，足球——可以说是人类历史上最受欢迎的活动。我是说，它的追随者比我们以往任何休闲活动都要多。仅凭这一点，它就具有令人难以置信的吸引力。
And that was a justification we had for doing an earlier episode on football with friend of the show jonathan wilson but also like the olympics it provides a kind of four yearly temperature check on the state of geopolitics and if you think about all the arguments that there currently are about qatar the questions about bribery about about corruption, about the lives lost in indentured labor, building the stadia, the cultural sensitivities around Qatar holding it. This is absolutely the stuff of 21st century politics. And it's almost impossible to think of a World Cup, and it goes right the way back to 1930, that hasn't in some way held a mirror up to the convulsions and the turbulence in the
这也是我们之前邀请节目之友乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson）来制作一期足球节目的理由。但就像奥运会一样，它每四年为我们提供一次地缘政治现状的温度计。如果你想想当前关于卡塔尔的所有争论——关于贿赂的质疑、关于腐败的质疑、在修建体育场的强制劳动中丧生的生命、卡塔尔举办世界杯所涉及的文化敏感性——这绝对是21世纪政治的题材。而且几乎无法想象有一届世界杯（可以追溯到1930年）没有在某种程度上成为广阔世界中动荡与风暴的镜子。
broader world. And I think it makes it an absolutely fascinating topic. And I speak as someone who really didn't know much about the World Cup before I started reading about it, the history of it. It's really extraordinary, really fascinating. I agree, Tom. I think it is fascinating because I think once we get into the story, it becomes actually a story not about, you know, so-and-so crossed the ball into the box and somebody else headed it, you know, a towering header into the back of the net. It's actually a story about nationalism, about the invention of national identity, about the way that often authoritarian regimes co-opt kind of popular entertainment. And so there are characters that run through this story. I mean, Mussolini is there, the Argentine hunter of the 1970s, you know, the Hungarian communist regime.
我认为这使它成为了一个绝对迷人的话题。而我是在自己开始阅读世界杯历史之前，对它其实并不太了解的人。这真的非同寻常，非常吸引人。我同意，汤姆。我认为它之所以迷人，是因为一旦我们进入这个故事，它实际上讲述的就不再是“某某把球传进禁区，然后另一个人一个回头望月，把球顶入网窝”的故事。它实际上是一个关于民族主义的故事，关于民族身份塑造的故事，关于威尼斯政权等集权统治者如何将大众娱乐收编的故事。所以这个故事里贯穿着许多人物。我是说，墨索里尼在里面，1970年代的阿根廷军政府，还有匈牙利共产主义政权。
There are so many interesting kind of characters. North Korea? I mean, amazing. Exactly, yes. I mean, Jules Rimet, you mentioned Jules Rimet. So Jules Rimet was the third president of FIFA in the 1920s. I mean, Jules Rimet, you mentioned Jules Rimet. So Jules Rimet was the third president of FIFA in the 1920s. I mean, Jules Rimet, you'll be pleased to hear, since you're interested in the history of religion, Tom, that he had been profoundly influenced by Pope Leo XIII's encyclical
这里有太多有趣的人物了。朝鲜？我的天，太神奇了。确实如此，没错。我是说，儒勒·雷米特，你提到了儒勒·雷米特。儒勒·雷米特是1920年代国际足联的第三任主席。我是说，儒勒·雷米特，你提到了儒勒·雷米特。所以儒勒·雷米特是1920年代国际足联的第三任主席。我是说，儒勒·雷米特——听到这个你可能会高兴，既然你对宗教史感兴趣，汤姆——他曾深受教皇利奥十三世（Pope Leo XIII）关于劳工尊严的通谕《新事》（Rerum Novarum）的深远影响。
about the dignity of work, Rerum Novarum. I think that's evident in every aspect of the World Cup. Well, Rimet had served in the French Army in World War I. He'd won the Croix de Guerre. and then he's the classic person in the 1920s who sort of lets all be friends yes well he i mean he says when he when he's making his pitch to to his fellow colleagues at fifa in 1928 he says you know we must encourage mankind to be one thanks to football i mean that's a real 1920s league of nations thing to say isn't it absolutely it's in real 1920s League of Nations thing to say, isn't it? Absolutely.
我认为这在世界杯的方方面面都显而易见。嗯，雷米特曾在第一次世界大战中服役于法国军队。他曾荣获英勇十字勋章（Croix de Guerre）。然后他成了1920年代那种主张“大家都做朋友吧”的经典人物。是的，当他在1928年向国际足联的同僚们进行游说时，他说：“你知道，我们必须借助足球，鼓励全人类成为一家人。”我的天，这真是一句非常具有1920年代国际联盟（League of Nations）风格的话，不是吗？绝对是的，这真是一句非常有1920年代国际联盟风格的话，不是吗？绝对是的。
Yeah, because it's in the aftermath of the First World War. Yeah. So it's, I think, absolutely brilliant. So, Dominic. Yes. The lead-in. Yes. How is it that we have the Olympics kick off in 1896,
对，因为这正值第一次世界大战之后。对。所以，我认为这真是太精彩了。那么，多米尼克。什么。关于开篇。对。为什么我们在1896年就迎来了奥运会的开幕，
but we don't get a World Cup until 1930? Or do we, Tom? Or do we? Okay. Because it's all to do with the Olympicslympics isn't it it is so let's if we pull the camera right back why do we have a world cup at all my answer which some people may find kind of surprising i would say the world cup is is clearly a product of the british empire and that will surprise people because they'll think of british empire sports as cricket and
而直到1930年才有了世界杯？或者说，汤姆，真的是这样吗？还是说其实并非如此？好吧。因为这全跟奥运会有关系，不是吗？确实如此。所以如果我们把镜头拉远，为什么我们要办世界杯？我的答案——有些人可能会觉得有点惊讶——我会说世界杯显然是英国殖民帝国的产物。这会让人感到惊讶，因为他们会把大英帝国的体育运动联想到板球和
rugby and not not necessarily as football But if you look at the two countries that I would say to most people, certainly in Europe, they think they are sort of immediately identified with the World Cup. They're Brazil and Argentina. Neither of those countries were officially part of the empire. But if you take Argentina, for example, we know that British sailors were playing some kind of football in the mid-19th century when they were visiting Buenos Aires. Argentina had a big, big British population, so the largest British and Irish population outside the empire. The British were involved in banking, in trade, in the railways, and all these kinds of things. So Argentina was a kind of informal part
橄榄球，而不一定会想到足球。但如果你看看那两个我认为对大多数人来说（尤其是在欧洲）会立即与世界杯联系起来的国家，它们是巴西和阿根廷。这两个国家都不是帝国官方的一部分。但以阿根廷为例，我们知道英国水手在19世纪中叶造访布宜诺斯艾利斯时就在踢某种足球。阿根廷有着庞大的英国人社群——可以说是帝国以外最大的英国和爱尔兰移民群体。英国人涉足银行业、贸易、铁路以及诸如此类的各种领域。所以阿根廷可以说是帝国的一种非正式部分，
of the of the empire i suppose um there's a they're playing cricket before they play football well that's what i found so interesting is that in in brazil as well as in argentina yeah again and again it's actually cricket clubs that's it is it is absolutely i mean that's so and and also of course in in um in in AC Milan. AC Milan, of course. But also the first football match played in Austria. Did you know this? I didn't. It was played by the Vienna Cricket Club.
我想……他们在踢足球之前其实是在踢板球。嗯，这就是我发现最有趣的地方，在巴西和阿根廷都是如此，对，一次又一次，其实都是板球俱乐部。确实如此。我的天，真是这样，而且当然还有，嗯，在……在AC米兰。AC米兰，当然。但不仅如此，在奥地利踢的第一场足球比赛——你知道这件事吗？我不知道。它是维也纳板球俱乐部踢的。
I didn't know this. So I know that you've secretly behind my back been obtaining facts from my former university teammate, Jonathan Wilson, historian of football. Yes, I have. So I took him out for a meal. This is absolutely the difference between us tom that you i spend the evening swatting up on jonathan wilson's books and you take him out for dinner yes but i would also i on this topic um i would highly commend
我竟然不知道这事。我知道你背着我偷偷从我前大学队友、足球历史学家乔纳森·威尔逊那里套取事实。是的，没错。所以我请他吃了一顿饭。这绝对是你我之间的区别，汤姆：我会花一整个晚上恶补乔纳森·威尔逊的书，而你则是请他吃晚餐。是的，但关于这个话题，嗯，我极力推荐
uh a new book that's just come out by uh two brothers stewart and philip laycock called how britain brought football to the world which has a splendid cover of a chap in very baggy football trousers, smoking a pipe with his foot on a very heavy leather football. And it goes through every country in the world saying how it was that it came to take up football. So back to Argentina, you mentioned the cricket club. So it's at Buenos Aires Cricket Club that a guy called Thomas Hogg, his father had been a yorkshire textile factory owner and thomas hogg is one of these absolutely classic late 19th century british figures he organizes a swimming club which he calls the
由斯图尔特·莱科克（Stuart Laycock）和菲利普·莱科克（Philip Laycock）这对兄弟刚刚出版的新书，书名叫《英国是如何将足球带给世界的》（How Britain Brought Football to the World）。书的封面非常棒，画着一个穿着极宽松足球裤、叼着烟斗的家伙，把脚搭在一个非常重的皮质足球上。书中梳理了世界上每一个国家是如何开始接受足球的。所以回到阿根廷，你提到了板球俱乐部。正是在布宜诺斯艾利斯板球俱乐部（Buenos Aires Cricket Club），一个叫托马斯·霍格（Thomas Hogg）的家伙——他的父亲曾是约克郡的一名纺织厂老板——托马斯·霍格是1920年代那种极其典型的英国人物，他组织了一个游泳俱乐部，在布宜诺斯艾利斯将其命名为
dreadnought swimming club in buenos aires he establishes an athletics club he sets up the south america's first golf club it's the energy isn't it it's exhausting and then eventually in 1867 he places an advert saying let's have a meeting to play football at the cricket ground and and they do and um it obviously takes off and it's actually so in a way that you could say the ancestor of the world cup is this match in 1888 that is organised by British expats in Buenos Aires to play their counterparts from Montevideo in Uruguay. So that's just across the kind of the mouth of the river plate, basically.
“无畏”游泳俱乐部（Dreadnought swimming club），他建立了一个田径俱乐部，创立了南美洲第一个高尔夫俱乐部。这股精力，简直令人精疲力竭。然后最终在1867年，他在板球场登广告称：让我们开个会来踢足球吧。他们照做了，这显然风靡一时。所以在某种意义上，你可以说世界杯的鼻祖，就是1888年由在布宜诺斯艾利斯的英国侨民组织的一场比赛，他们与来自乌拉圭蒙得维的亚的同行们进行比赛。这基本上就是越过拉普拉塔河口。
They're going to play against their sort of neighbours to celebrate the birthday of Queen Victoria. That is the perfect genesis for the World Cup. It's South American rivalries. Yeah. Interfused with kind of British imperial primness. Well, because as people who like football will know, Argentina versus Uruguay is the first World Cup final in 1930.
他们准备和各自的邻居踢球，来庆祝维多利亚女王的生日。这简直是世界杯最完美的起源。这是南美洲的宿敌对决。是的。其中融入了英国帝国式的刻板拘谨。嗯，正如喜爱足球的人所知，阿根廷对阵乌拉圭正是1930年第一届世界杯的决赛。
Yeah. So then it sort of takes on that Brazil. So Brazil is the country that most people associate with the World Cup final in 1930. So then it sort of takes on that Brazil. So Brazil is the country that most people associate with the World Cup ultimately, because they want it more often than anybody else. And we'll be coming back to Brazil later on. Brazil is actually a similar story. They're less intertwined with the British.
所以它开始演变成……巴西。所以巴西是人们最终最常与世界杯决赛联系在一起的国家，因为他们夺冠的次数比任何人都多。我们稍后会再谈到巴西。巴西的情况其实也差不多。他们与英国人的交集没有那么深。
So they adopt football a little bit later, but it's exactly the same thing. There's a guy in Brazil, a legendary figure called Charles Miller. He's the son of a scottish um businessman another cricketer he's another cricketer he's been sent off to boarding school in england and there's this sort of great story that he tells himself in his memoirs he comes back home from university and he gets off the key and santos actually sant, actually Santos is the port city with the club of which Pele played for.
所以他们接受足球的时间稍微晚了一点，但情况完全一样。巴西有个传奇人物叫查尔斯·米勒（Charles Miller）。他是一个苏格兰商人的儿子，嗯，也是个板球运动员。他也是个板球运动员。他被送去英格兰寄宿学校上学，在他自传中有一个非常棒的故事：他从大学回到家，在桑托斯下了码头——桑托斯其实是一个港口城市，贝利曾效力于那里的俱乐部。
He gets off the key at Santos and his father was expecting him to be holding his degree certificate. And actually he's holding the rules of the game and two footballs. And his father said, the old man, he says, said, what's this Charles? My degree, I replied.
他在桑托斯下了码头，而他父亲本期望他手里拿的是学位证书。但实际上，他手里拿的是比赛规则和两个足球。他父亲——那个老头说：“查尔斯，这是什么？”“我的学位，我回答道。”
What? Yes, your son has graduated in football. And then Miller sort of goes and plays. Again, they're playing at cricket clubs. They have two teams, one from Sao Paulo Railway, one from the gas team. Then it spreads to the Rio Cricket Club and so on and so forth. But the funny thing is actually, Tom, thinking,
“什么？是的，你儿子在足球专业毕业了。”然后米勒就去踢球了。同样地，他们也是在板球俱乐部踢球。他们有两支球队，一支来自圣保罗铁路公司，一支来自燃气公司。后来它传到了里约板球俱乐部，诸如此类。但有趣的是，汤姆，想想看，
we'll come back to Brazil and how much, how important football is to Brazil's national identity. But first of all, quite often in these places, people react with incredulity and horror at the spectacle of Englishmen playing football. So there's a newspaper report in Rio. I'm guessing this is from the 1890s. It says, in Bom Retiro, a group of Englishmen,
我们稍后会回到巴西，看看足球对巴西的国家认同有多么重要。但首先，在这些地方，人们往往对英国人踢球的奇观抱有难以置信的惊愕和恐惧。所以里约的一份报纸曾有这样一篇报道。我猜这是19世纪90年代的。上面写道：在邦雷蒂罗（Bom Retiro），有一群英国人，
a bunch of maniacs as they all are, get together from time to time to kick around something that looks like a bull's bladder. It gives them great satisfaction or fills them with sorrow when this kind of yellowish bladder enters a rectangle formed by wooden posts. Or in Sao Paulo, somebody writes, they call it a blind and balmy battle of physical force.
全是一群疯子，时不时聚在一起，踢一个看起来像牛膀胱一样的东西。当这个黄油般的气囊进入由木桩围成的矩形时，会给他们带来极大的满足，或者让他们陷入悲伤。或者在圣保罗，有人写道：他们称这是一场盲目而愚蠢的体力对抗战。
Football is an English game and should only be played by the English. But of course it isn't. It spreads. It's taken up by the rich and then it spreads, percolates downwards. But having said that, of course, I mean, it is being played by the English and indeed by the Scots and the Welsh and the Irish. And so they have. So the earliest international match is Scotland against England, isn't it? That's right.
足球是一项英国运动，理应只由英国人来踢。但事实当然并非如此。它蔓延开了。先是被富人们接受，然后向下渗透。话虽如此，当然了，我的意思是，它确实是由英国人、以及苏格兰人、威尔士人和爱尔兰人踢的。所以他们也……因此最早的国际比赛是苏格兰对阵英格兰，对吧？没错。
And then there's a championship is set up where all the home nations in the United Kingdom play one another. And that is seen by people in Britain, basically, as what other international competition do you need? We invented the game. We're the home of the sport. We don't need to bother about anything else. But they do set up football in the Olympics, don't they? And obviously the Olympics is for amateurs. And so in 1908, Great Britain beats Denmark, wins the gold.
然后成立了一个锦标赛，联合王国所有的本土国家都在其中互相交手。在英国人看来，这基本上就是：你还需要什么其他的国际比赛？我们发明了这项运动。我们是这项运动的发源地。我们不需要操心其他任何事情。但他们确实在奥运会上组建了足球队，不是吗？而且奥运会显然是为业余选手准备的。所以在1908年，英国击败了丹麦，赢得了金牌。
Following Olympics in Stockholm, 1912, same result. Britain beats Denmark. So hurrah, we are top nation. Top footballing nation. And no one in Britain doubts that. So this story is often told as a story. I mean, you'll see it again and again. People talk about British insularity and xenophobia,
随后的1912年斯德哥尔摩奥运会，结果相同。英国击败丹麦。所以，太棒了，我们是顶级国家。顶级足球强国。英国没有任何人对此产生怀疑。所以这个故事经常被当作这样一个故事来讲述——你会一次又一次地看到它——人们谈论英国人的孤立主义和仇外心理，
and that's why Britain doesn't join in, the British sort of misguided sense of superiority. I'm not quite sure about that. That just feels like it's repeated so often that it's become a cliche. I think the truth is Britain doesn't need the World Cup. Because the infrastructure is there, isn't it? Right. Countries that care about the World Cup are often ones that have, frankly, have something
这就是为什么英国不愿加入的原因，英国人那种被误导的优越感。我对这一点持保留意见。这感觉就像是被重复了太多次，以至于成了一种陈词滥调。我认为事实是，英国根本不需要世界杯。因为基础设施已经完备了，不是吗？没错。关心世界杯的国家，往往是那些坦率地说有什么东西
to prove. So South American countries that have only been independent for 100 years or so, later on, countries like Hungary, that again, is a sort of post-imperial, post-war country trying to establish its own national identity. In Britain, you have this existing ecosystem with this immensely popular tournament the home nations tournament with all this sort of competitive club football and basically nobody really cares about the prospect of playing matches against paraguay or or whatever it doesn't mean anything yeah so so yes there's
需要去证明的国家。比如那些独立才刚满一百年左右的南美国家；再后来，像匈牙利这样的国家，同样也是一个后帝国、战后试图确立自身国家认同的国家。在英国，你已经拥有现有的生态系统，拥有这个极受欢迎的锦标赛——本土锦标赛——拥有所有这些充满竞争的俱乐部足球，基本上没有人真正关心与巴拉圭或其他什么国家踢比赛的前景，那毫无意义。所以，是的，
the british do do well in those first olymp But actually, to go back to the World Cup itself, the first World Cup final most people will know is in 1930, and it's won by Uruguay. But if you look at Uruguay's shirts, instead of having the two stars on their blue shirts to signify they've won the World Cup twice, they have four stars. And the reason is that two of the Olympics before the World Cup count as World Cups because they were organized by FIFA. So those are the Olympics of 1924 and 1928. And Uruguay's story, actually. So Uruguay, just like Argentina and Brazil, there's a British pioneer.
英国人在早期的奥运会上确实表现出色。但实际上，回过头来看世界杯本身，大多数人都会知道，第一届世界杯决赛是在1930年，由乌拉圭赢得。但如果你看看乌拉圭的球衣，他们的蓝色球衣上并没有绣上两颗星来代表他们曾两次赢得世界杯，而是绣了四星。原因在于，在世界杯之前的那两届奥运会被算作了世界杯，因为它们是由国际足联组织的。这就是1924年和1928年的奥运会。而乌拉圭的故事，实际上……所以乌拉圭，就像阿根廷和巴西一样，也有一个英国先驱。
In this case, it's a Glaswegian called John Harley. He went to work as a draftsman and the railway lines first in Argentina and then in Uruguay he became the player manager of the big Montevideo team Peñarol he played for Uruguay so that was quite common yeah in the early days that basically expats would play it's very like in cricket world cups where you'll have I don't know Romania yeah and there'll be one Romanian and everyone else will be from kind of India or Sri Lanka yeah well I mean they start out. I mean, that first match that we were talking about
在这个案例中，是一个名叫约翰·哈利（John Harley）的格拉斯哥人。他先是以绘图员身份前往阿根廷的铁路线工作，后来又去了乌拉圭。他成为了蒙得维的亚大俱乐部佩纳罗尔（Peñarol）的球员兼教练，他还为乌拉圭国家队效力。这在早期非常普遍，基本上侨民都会去踢球。这非常像板球世界杯，你会看到，我不知道，罗马尼亚，然后里面有一个罗马尼亚人，其余所有人其实都来自印度或斯里兰卡。嗯，我的意思是，他们最初就是这样。我是说，我们刚才谈到的那场比赛
played for Queen Victoria's birthday. They're expat teams. Yeah. That's what these national teams were. So Uruguay, what John Harley does is he introduces the Scottish style. So the English had always played a very, very physical direct game,
是为了庆祝维多利亚女王的生日而踢的。它们都是侨民球队。对。这些国家队就是这样产生的。所以乌拉圭，约翰·哈利所做的事情，就是引入了苏格兰式的踢法。因为英国人一直踢的是非常非常注重身体对抗、直接长传冲吊的比赛，
kind of kick and rush. The Scots had done something disgraceful. They'd started passing the ball between themselves. That is shocking. Instead of just booting it up, hoofing it and running after it in public school manner. So John Harley introduced this. The Eurogrinds played very successfully.
有点像“大脚开球加冲刺”。而苏格兰人则做了一件大逆不道的事。他们开始在队友之间传球了。这太令人震惊了。而不是像公立学校的作风那样，一脚把球大脚踢到前场然后跟上去猛追。所以约翰·哈利引入了这种风格。乌拉圭人踢得非常成功。
They often beat their neighbours. So the 1924 Olympics is the first one where the football tournament is organized by fifa so that's why fifa recognized it as a kind of proto world cup and the uruguayans take that very very seriously so they're the classic example of a of a small country that is sort of has always been squeezed by its gigantic neighbours, Brazil and Argentina. It's basically Montevideo and its hinterland, the port city. And the Uruguayans are very keen to prove themselves. Thanks to this Glaswegian guy,
他们经常击败邻居。因此，1924年奥运会是足球锦标赛首次由国际足联组织的一届，这就是为什么国际足联承认它是一种“准世界杯”，而乌拉圭人对此极其认真。所以他们是一个典型的例子：一个小国，一直被其巨大的邻国巴西和阿根廷所挤压。它基本上就是蒙得维的亚及其腹地——那个港口城市。乌拉圭人非常渴望证明自己。多亏了这个格拉斯哥人，
they've got this sort of forward-thinking game. And so off they go to Paris. So it's 1924. It's the Charity Sapphire Olympics, Tom. Yes, and it's the Olympics where WB Yeats' brother wins Ireland's first Olympic medal with his painting. With his painting? Yeah.
他们拥有了一种前瞻性的踢法。于是他们出发前往巴黎。那是1924年。那是查里蒂·萨菲尔（Charity Sapphire）奥运会，汤姆。是的，那是叶芝（WB Yeats）的兄弟凭绘画赢得爱尔兰第一枚奥运奖牌的奥运会。凭绘画？对。
Do you remember? We had that in the Olympics episode. He puts in a painting, wins silver. Brilliant. But not gold, tragically. No, no. Silver's pretty good. Do we know who beat him?
你还记得吗？我们在奥运会那一集里讲过这个。他交了一幅画，赢得了银牌。太棒了。但很悲惨的是，没有拿到金牌。不，不。银牌已经相当不错了。我们知道是谁击败了他吗？
Picasso or something. I don't know. Bring it home for Spain. Right. So the Uruguayansans so the uruguayan fa um they pay themselves for the team to go one of the uruguayan fa bigwigs actually mortgages his house and so this is the issue with the british teams isn't it and indeed with the danish teams where people can afford to be amateurs yes the corinthian spirit um the idea that that people have to be paid to play sport is shocking to the kind of british bigwigs who run their sporting associations exactly and so when is it is it 1928 the british pull out of fifa because the olympics are are meant to be amateur yeah but but they're agreeing to pay they're not paying them to play
毕加索还是什么的。我不知道。为西班牙把奖牌带回家。好吧。所以乌拉圭人……所以乌拉圭足协，他们自己出资让球队去参赛。乌拉圭足协的一位大人物实际上把自己的房子拿去抵押了。所以这就是英国球队的问题所在，对吧？确实，丹麦球队也是如此，人们能够负担得起作为业余选手的开销。是的，科林蒂安精神（Corinthian spirit）——那种认为人们必须获得报酬才能进行体育运动的想法，对运营体育协会的英国大人物来说是令人震惊的。没错。那么，是哪一年？是1928年吗？英国人退出了国际足联，因为奥运会应该是由业余选手参加的？对，但他们当时同意支付补偿，他们不是付钱让他们踢球，
are they but they're subsidizing the wages. What they're doing is they're saying, it's called broken time payments. It's a bit of a swizz, really. They basically say, you can pay people for the work they would have done if they hadn't taken time off work to go and play in this amateur tournament.
对吧？但他们在补贴工资。他们所做的是，这被称为“误工补偿”（broken time payments）。这其实有点像个骗局。他们基本上是说，你可以付钱给那些为了参加这个业余锦标赛而请假的人，补偿他们本该得到的工资。
And of course, the associations basically, you know, completely abuse that to, to, to, to pay their players professionally. So the Uruguayans, I mean, the people who go,
当然，各个协会基本上，你知道，彻底滥用了这一点，来作为职业球员向他们支付薪水。所以乌拉圭人——我是说，那些去的人，
so folklore has it that they are a marble cutter, a meat packer, a guy who plays music in carnivals, all this sort of a boot black, all these kinds of things. But actually, of course they are extremely skillful professionals professional players exactly so they go off to um to paris the uruguayans all these journeys have this sort of comic opera sides to them don't they they go on
民间传说他们是一个石雕工、一个肉类打包工、一个在狂欢节上玩音乐的家伙，诸如此类的，还有一个擦鞋匠，所有这些各种各样的人。但实际上，当然，他们是极其娴熟的职业球员。职业球员，没错。所以他们前往巴黎，乌拉圭人……所有这些旅程都有点滑稽歌剧（comic opera）的色彩，不是吗？他们坐船去，
so this is one of the abiding themes throughout the early years is that the challenge of travel isn't it yeah that actually you know taking 11 people well more i mean a squad um with with the manager whatever across the atlantic or into the depths of brazil or whatever i mean it's actually quite challenging yeah it's a massive operation again and again there comes some quite so my favorite one is um in uh in 1934 when when it's held in italy and the mexican team comes across thinking that they've qualified, arrive, find that they haven't. So they have to play a qualifying round against the United States,
所以这是早期岁月里一个挥之不去的主题，那就是旅行的挑战，对吧？是的，实际上，你知道，带着11个人——或者说更多，我是说一个阵容——带着经理或者不管是谁，横渡大西洋，或者深入巴西腹地什么的，我的意思是，这其实相当具有挑战性。是的，这是一项庞大的行动。一次又一次，会出现一些非常……我最喜欢的一个故事是，在1934年，当比赛在意大利举行时，墨西哥队横渡大西洋过来，以为自己已经晋级了，结果到达后发现并没有。所以他们不得不与美国队进行一场附加赛，
lose, and go back. You know, that's a long way to come. That's a hell of a way to go. And never even to play in the World Cup. So for Uruguayans in 1924, they have to help pay for this. They do a tour of Spain first. So they get the boat to Spain. They play all these matches in Spain, and they go off to Paris.
输了，然后又回去了。你知道，大老远跑来。那可真是条漫长的路。而且甚至都没能在世界杯上踢上一场。所以对于1924年的乌拉圭人来说，他们必须自己出钱出力。他们首先去西班牙进行了一场巡回赛。所以他们坐船去西班牙。他们在西班牙踢了所有这些比赛，然后前往巴黎。
When they get to Paris, they think the Olympic village is terrible. So they rent or they find a chateau owned by the brilliantly named woman called Madame Pain, Mrs. Bread. So Mrs. Bread assumes this sort of folkloric position. She's the kind of mothers them. Exactly. She mothers them. So they storm through the tournament.
当他们到达巴黎时，他们觉得奥运村糟糕透顶。于是他们租下了一座城堡，或者说找到了一座城堡，这座城堡属于一个名字极其动听的女性，名叫佩恩夫人（Madame Pain），也就是“面包夫人”。所以“面包夫人”承担了这种民间传说般的地位。她有点像他们的母亲……没错。她像母亲一样照顾他们。于是他们势如破竹地杀入锦标赛，
They win the tournament. They beat the Swiss in the final. They get back to Uruguay. There's a national holiday. The government issues stamps. It's a huge, huge deal. And actually not just for Uruguay, but for South America generally. So the Argentine paper El Grafico, I think Jonathan Wilson talks about this in his brilliant history of Argentine football, Angels with Dirty Faces.
赢得了比赛。他们在决赛中击败了瑞士人。他们回到乌拉圭。全国放假。政府发行了邮票。这是一件极其轰动的大事。而且不仅对乌拉圭是这样，对整个南美洲也是如此。所以阿根廷的《图画报》（El Grafico）——我想乔纳森·威尔逊在他那本精彩的阿根廷足球史《带着肮脏面孔的天使》（Angels with Dirty Faces）中谈到过这一点——
Epic yet intimate, a distinguished critic. Is that what you called it? That's what I called it. Right, of course. Not influenced at all by the fact that you play cricket together. No, it's genuinely, it's a brilliant book. It is a brilliant book. Not just a history of Argentine football, but history of argentina i believe i also said as he
史诗般而又亲切，一位杰出的评论家。你是这么叫它的吗？我是这么叫它的。对，当然。这绝不受你们一起打过板球这一事实的影响。不，这真的是一本精彩的书。这确实是一本精彩的书。不仅是阿根廷足球史，更是阿根廷的历史。我相信我也说过，正如他
always says it's not really a football book it's a history book uh el grafico says said millions of maps were sold in paris to people who wanted to know exactly where that tiny nation that is the home of the football artist was and soon there will be argentinian and uruguayan clubs going to europe just as the english came to south america to show us and teach us football so there's this sense even then in the 1920s you know this is it's not quite revenge but it's basically the boot is on the other foot the english have been patronizing us all these decades the student is schooling the master exactly exactly it's darth vader and obi-wan kenobi tom for for if you like star wars which i know you
一直所说的，这其实不是一本足球书，而是一本历史书。《图画报》说：巴黎卖出了数百万张地图，给那些想要知道那个作为足球艺术家发源地的微小国家究竟在哪里的人。很快，阿根廷和乌拉圭的俱乐部也将前往欧洲，就像当初英国人来到南美洲向我们展示并教授我们足球一样。所以在那个时候——1920年代——就已经有这种感觉了，你知道，这虽然算不上复仇，但基本上是风水轮流转。英国人这些年来一直在我们面前居高临下，现在是学生在教育老师了。没错，没错。这简直就是《星球大战》里的达斯·维德和欧比旺·克诺比，汤姆，如果你喜欢《星球大战》的话——但我知道你不喜欢，所以你根本不知道我在说什么。
don't so you won't you won't know what i'm talking about I don't of course I know what you're talking about so 1928 the Uruguayans go again don't they they go to they go to Amsterdam this time this time they play Argentina so Uruguay Argentina is the great rivalry well and in 1924 it results in their first use of a fence to separate players from spectators. Is that right? Yeah. You're full of Argentina and Uruguay. Very good. It's a top fact. So the Uruguayans win, and the British have left FIFA completely by this point.
我当然知道你在说什么。所以1928年乌拉圭人再次出征，不是吗？他们去了，这次他们去了阿姆斯特丹。这一次他们对阵阿根廷。所以乌拉圭对阿根廷是一场伟大的宿敌对决。顺便在1924年，这导致了他们首次使用栅栏来将球员与观众隔开。是这样吗？是的。你对阿根廷和乌拉圭的历史可以说是了如指掌。太棒了。这是一个顶级的冷知识。所以乌拉圭人赢了，而英国人此时已经完全退出了国际足联。
It's partly amateurism. Actually, the British were also, they'd had a rift with FIFA because they didn't like the fact that FIFA had admitted the central powers from World War I. I think the justifications are stacking up. Well, actually, the British will redeem themselves on that front when we come back to the aftermath of World War II, when they were very keen on letting their old antagonists back in.
部分原因是业余主义。实际上，英国人也曾与国际足联产生过裂隙，因为他们不喜欢国际足联接纳了一战中的同盟国（中央同盟国）。看来这些借口的叠罗汉还在继续。嗯，实际上，当我们回到二战后的余波时，英国人将在这一方面自我救赎，当时他们非常热衷于让他们的老对手重新加入。
So those first two, those are, I mean, I was going to say those first two World Cups. The Uruguayans would say they are World Cups. So Uruguay gets its first two wins and then there's the first official World Cup in 1930. And that's played in Uruguay for obvious reasons. They're the best team, but also Uruguay is celebrating
所以前两届——我是说前两届世界杯。乌拉圭人会认为它们就是世界杯。所以乌拉圭获得了前两次冠军，然后就是1930年的第一届官方世界杯。这场比赛理所当然地在乌拉圭举行。他们是最好的球队，而且乌拉圭正在庆祝
the centenary of its independence, but also Montevideo has remained relatively immune from the Wall Street crash and the onset of the Great Depression. Whereas Argentina is terrible, isn't it? Well, Argentina is sort of entering, preparing to enter its long-running basket case phase. Also, they've built a spanking brand new stadium, haven't they?
其独立百年庆典，同时蒙得维的亚也相对免疫于华尔街股灾和大萧条的爆发。而阿根廷则糟糕透顶，不是吗？嗯，阿根廷正处于、正准备进入其长期的“烂摊子”阶段。而且他们还修建了一座崭新的宏伟体育场，不是吗？
Which is very much a World Cup tradition. They have. They've built this stadium to mark their 100th anniversary of their independence, the Centenario Stadium. And also the Uruguayans say they will match they will meet the expenses of everybody who comes and we should we should preview here that um we're doing a world cup marathon that actually has nothing whatsoever to do with football uh we're doing 32 episodes because there are 32 countries playing and we're doing
这非常符合世界杯的传统。他们确实建了。他们建造这座体育场是为了纪念他们独立100周年，即世纪体育场（Centenario Stadium）。而且乌拉圭人还表示，他们将承担所有来宾的费用。我们在这里也应该预告一下，嗯，我们将举办一场世界杯马拉松，它其实与足球完全没有任何关系——我们将制作32集节目，因为有32支参赛球队，我们将
um an episode a day on an aspect of the history of all these various countries. And in the episode that we've already recorded on Uruguay, you make the point that Uruguay was a very, very rich country. And that sporting success tends to be associated with wealthy countries for obvious reasons, because they can afford to invest in the infrastructure. And that's what Uruguay is able to do in 1930. Exactly. It is a very prosperous country. It has a kind of proto-welfare state. It's very
每天播出一集，聚焦所有这些不同国家的历史的一个方面。在我们已经录制的关于乌拉圭的那集节目中，你指出乌拉圭曾经是一个非常非常富有的国家。而体育上的成功往往与富裕国家联系在一起，原因很明显，因为他们有能力投资基础设施。这就是乌拉圭在1930年能够做到的事情。完全正确。这是一个非常繁荣的国家。它拥有某种准福利国家体制。它非常
forward-looking. And this is part of that. For the Uruguayan government, football is a way to advertise Uruguay as otherwise little noticed countries of the world. So you have these amazing stories. I know you love all these stories about steamships
具有前瞻性。这也是其中的一部分。对乌拉圭政府而言，足球是一种向世界宣传乌拉圭这个原本不太引人注目的国家的方式。所以你会有这些神奇的故事。我知道你喜欢所有这些关于轮船
and people crossing the Atlantic. There was a brilliant article actually in The Guardian by a guy called Simon Burnton about this. And he talks about the ship. So the ship is called the Conte Verde and it was built in Glasgow, but it was built for the Genoese. It was named after a 14th century count of Savoy.
和人们横渡大西洋的故事。英国《卫报》（The Guardian）上实际上有一篇非常精彩的文章，作者是一个叫西蒙·伯恩顿（Simon Burnton）的人，他在文中谈到了一艘船。这艘船名叫“孔特·韦尔德号”（Conte Verde），它在格拉斯哥建造，但却是为热那亚人建造的。它是以一位14世纪的萨伏依伯爵命名的。
And this ship, which later goes on to be bombed in the Second World War because it's taken over by the Japanese, it sets off from Genoa in the summer of 1930. The first people aboard are the Romanians. The Romanians are going to the World Cup. So you don't have to qualify. It's basically anyone can go.
这艘船后来在第二次世界大战中被日本人接管并不幸遭轰炸。它于1930年夏天从热那亚启航。第一批登船的是罗马尼亚人。罗马尼亚人要去踢世界杯。所以你甚至不需要参加预选赛。基本上谁都能去。
Well, because most Europeans refuse to go. I mean, initially, they all refuse to go. And so Gilles Rimet kind of leans on people, doesn't he? And it's the king of Romania. King Carol. He personally funds them to go and so you remake kind of leans on people doesn't yeah and it's the king of romania king carol he personally funds them to go and they're all people who work for british oil companies in romania because that's why they've been playing football in romania so they they all go on board and then they pick up the french then they pick up the belgians in barcelona and then across they go the atlantic to rio where they're going to pick up the Brazilians. And so basically for 15 days, all these guys are on the boat.
嗯，因为大多数欧洲人拒绝前往。我是说，最初他们全都拒绝去。所以儒勒·雷米特有点在对大家施压，不是吗？那是罗马尼亚国王。卡罗尔国王。他亲自资助他们去参赛。所以雷米特有点在施压，对吧？是的，那是罗马尼亚国王卡罗尔国王。他亲自资助他们去参赛。他们全都是在罗马尼亚的英国石油公司工作的人，这就是为什么他们一直在罗马尼亚踢足球。所以他们全都登上了船，然后他们去接了法国人，接着在巴塞罗那接了比利时人，然后横渡大西洋前往里约，去那里接巴西人。所以基本上有15天的时间，所有这些家伙都在船上。
And they're just running around all the time and lifting weights. Isn't there a swimming pool? There's a swimming pool. They have comedy acts. There are string quartets. It's basically, you know. Very Titanic. It's very Titanic, yeah.
他们一直在到处跑步、举重。难道没有游泳池吗？有一个游泳池。他们有喜剧表演。还有弦乐四重奏。基本上，你知道的。非常像泰坦尼克号。非常像泰坦尼克号，是的。
There's another boat that goes called the Florida. So that's got the Yugoslavs on board. And isn't there a team that doesn't, they miss their appointment? Right. Egypt. Egypt, that's right. Egypt we're going to go.
还有另一艘船叫“佛罗里达号”（Florida）。船上载着南斯拉夫人。难道没有一支球队……他们错过了预约吗？对，埃及。埃及，没错。埃及本来打算去的。
But there's a storm and they're delayed and they're crossing from Cairo. And the Yugoslavs sail without them. So that's why there are 13 teams rather than 14, which makes it rather tricky to make up. So they get to Uruguay. Uruguay are the clear favourites. They all look kind of very...
但遇到了一场风暴，他们延误了，他们从开罗出发。而南斯拉夫人没有等他们就起航了。这就是为什么参赛队伍是13支而不是14支，这让赛程编排变得相当棘手。他们到达了乌拉圭。乌拉圭是绝对的夺冠热门。他们看起来都非常……
So Bolivia are there, but Bolivia, they play in Berets, which I think is a nice touch. And of course, you mentioned Brazil, and they are the only country to have played in every World Cup. They are. But they're not very good in... They're not the superpower. And the USA is there?
玻利维亚也在那里，但玻利维亚人戴着贝雷帽踢球，我觉得这是一个不错的细节。当然，你提到了巴西，他们是唯一一支参加了每一届世界杯的国家。他们的确是。但他们在……他们当时还不是超级大国。美国也在那里吗？
The USA gets the semi-finals. So do you know what their nickname is? The Knickerbockers. No, the Shotputters. Why the Shot is there? The USA gets the semifinals. So do you know what their nickname is? The Knickerbockers. No, the Shotputters. Why the Shotputters? Because they were physically absolutely huge. They had massive great shoulders. The first sort of World Cup brawl is their match against Argentina.
美国闯入了半决赛。你知道他们的绰号是什么吗？灯笼裤（Knickerbockers）。不，铅球手（The Shotputters）。为什么叫铅球手？因为他们的身体体型绝对极其庞大。他们有着宽阔无比的肩膀。第一场类似世界杯群殴的比赛就是他们对阵阿根廷的比赛。
So Argentina beat them 6-1 in the semifinal. But this is when the manager runs up one american one american past plays on with a broken leg would you believe one american loses four teeth and has his lip ripped off uh one american has to be taken to hospital with a stomach injury and another american is left limping badly after somebody attempts to dislocate his knee. But my favourite story about that is the US manager who runs up to the referee to complain, but he's got a bottle of chloroform on him and he drops it and passes out.
阿根廷在半决赛中以6-1击败了他们。但这就是那个管理人员冲上场地的时候……有一个美国人……一个美国人带着断腿继续坚持踢比赛，你敢相信吗？一个美国人掉了四颗牙，嘴唇被撕裂了；一个美国人因为腹部受伤被送往医院；还有一个美国人在有人试图卸掉他的膝盖关节后一瘸一拐。但我对此最喜欢的的故事是，美国队经理冲向裁判抱怨，但他身上带着一瓶氯仿，结果不小心把它弄掉了，自己当场晕倒了。
Which, tremendous scenes. So the referees look splendid because the referees are wearing a shirt and tie. Which is so, honestly, I mean, I think... All referees should wear that. What wouldn would you give to see referees do that but i mean the the all the matches are full of amazing detail so um the first goal is scored by a frenchman um but the first goal scored by a uruguayan the striker only has one arm oh yes he lost his arm his arm as i think when he was kind of 13 or something,
真是精彩的场面。所以裁判们看起来风度翩翩，因为裁判们穿着衬衫和领带。老实说，我觉得……所有裁判都应该穿成那样。为了看裁判这么做，你愿意付出什么？我的意思是，所有的比赛都充满了令人惊叹的细节，所以……第一个进球是由一个法国人打进的，但乌拉圭人打进的第一个球，那个前锋只有一只胳膊。哦，是的。他失去了手臂，我想他当时大约13岁左右，
in a chainsaw accident. So basically, if your image of early World Cups, if you know nothing about football and your sort of supposition is that it's all people with wooden legs or, you know, playing in a shirt and tie. Absolutely right. Yeah, you're right. So there's the final, isn't there? And it's Uruguay against Argentina.
在一次链锯事故中。所以基本上，如果你对早期世界杯的印象——如果你对足球一无所知，你的设想是里面全都是装著木腿的人，或者你知道的，穿着衬衫和领带在踢球。完全正确。是的，你说得对。所以接下来就是决赛了，对吧？是乌拉圭对阵阿根廷。
The referee says, I will only play if you give me a police escort. And there is a ship primed and ready to take me away. That's right. And so Uruguay against Argentina. The referee says, I will only play if you give me a police escort. And there is a ship primed and ready to take me away. That's right. And so Uruguay wins. Argentina, you know, there's massive kind of rioting and all kinds of stuff. There's some hilarious stuff about it. So you're talking about Egypt missing their ship. So 15,000 Argentinians pack into these steamers to take them across the bay to Montevideo.
裁判说：“只有你们给我提供警察护卫，我才会执法。而且必须有一艘船已经做好准备随时把我接走。”没错。所以乌拉圭对阵阿根廷。裁判说：“只有你们给我提供警察护卫，我才会执法。而且必须有一艘船已经做好准备随时把我接走。”没错。所以乌拉圭赢了。阿根廷那边，你知道的，爆发了大规模的骚乱和各种各样的事情。这里面有一些极其搞笑的插曲。所以你刚才提到埃及错过了他们的船。有15,000名阿根廷人挤上这些轮船，乘船穿过海湾前往蒙得维的亚。
But there's terrible fog. So the steamers all get stuck in the fog and the Argentinians only get off the boat after the day after the match. To join in the fun of trashing the city. To find out that Uruguay won. So it's a massive, I mean, this was a massive deal.
但当时有可怕的浓雾。所以轮船全都被困在了雾里，阿根廷人直到比赛结束的第二天早上才下船。去加入打砸这座城市的狂欢中。结果发现乌拉圭已经赢了。所以这是一件大事，我的意思是，这是一件非常轰动的事。
There were riots in Buenos Aires. Two people were shot. A woman was stoned for waving the Uruguayan flag. Meanwhile, in Uruguay, all the victorious players, so they won 4-2. And actually, the guy with one arm plays, Hector Castro plays for Uruguay. The Uruguayans are all given a house by their government
布宜诺斯艾利斯发生了骚乱。两个人被枪杀。一名女子因为挥舞乌拉圭国旗而被投掷石头。与此同时，在乌拉圭，所有获胜的球员——他们以4-2获胜。实际上，那个只有一只胳膊的球员也上场了，埃克托·卡斯特罗（Hector Castro）为乌拉圭效力。乌拉圭人全都被他们的政府赠予了一栋房子，
as a reward for having... Fair enough, I think. Fair enough. It's a big deal. This, for people who think that the World Cup doesn't matter, this is why it does matter, historically speaking, because it amplifies the global role of that you get a sense of the kind of shadows spilling forward from the second world war uh the sense of of uh the horrors are to come so the french captain in 1944 he will be shot by the resistance as a nazi collaborator he ends up wearing the uniform the ss and the yugoslav captain the year before in 1943 will be shot by the nazis as a partisan and you you know you you think of the the world cup this corinthian spirit all this
作为他们……我觉得合情合理。合情合理。这可是件大事。对于那些认为世界杯无关紧要的人来说，这就是它在历史上至关重要的原因，因为它放大了全球角色，让你感受到来自第二次世界大战的阴影如何弥漫开来，感受到——即将到来的恐怖。所以1944年的法国队长后来被抵抗运动作为纳粹同僚枪决了，他最终穿上了党卫军的制服；而前一年，即1943年，南斯拉夫队长被纳粹作为游击队员枪决了。你会想到世界杯，这种科林蒂安精神，这一切
kind of stuff and yet you you have captains playing in it who are going to die in the war and lots of you know lots of others will but then also you have the two world cups that follow the one in 1937 34 and 38 and they are massively shadowed by the rise of fascism and the horrors that have come in the war. You're right, Tom. There's a bit of darkness ahead. But just before we get to the darkness, I'll tell you one last funny thing about the 1930 World Cup. So the Romanians go home on the transatlantic boat again, but one of has taken ill a guy called alfred eisenbeisser ferraru he's got he's taken with pneumonia when they get to genoa he's taken off the boat to to hospital to recuperate but basically what happens is the team will then go off without him and they arrive back in bucharest and everyone that the huge crowd gathers to see them and people notice
诸如此类的事情。然而，有些队长在比赛中踢球，他们随后将死于战争，你知道，还有许多其他人也是如此。但随后还有紧随其后的两届世界杯，即1934年和1938年的世界杯，这两届世界杯严重笼罩在法西斯主义的崛起以及战争带来的恐怖之中。你说得对，汤姆。前方有一点黑暗。但在我们进入黑暗之前，我再告诉你关于1930年世界杯最后一件趣事。罗马尼亚人又坐着横渡大西洋的船回家了，但其中一个人病倒了，一个叫阿尔弗雷德·艾森拜塞尔·费拉鲁的人。他得了肺炎，当他们到达热那亚时，他被带下船去医院休养，但基本上发生的情况是，球队随后在没有他的情况下出发了，他们回到了布加勒斯特，一大群人聚集来看望他们，人们注意到
that he hasn't got off the boat and a rumor spreads that he's dead that he's died in South America word of this reaches his mother and she organizes a wake to just as basically to mourn her son and on the morning of the wake he walks in front door and his mother takes one look at him and faints on the spot.
他没有下船，于是有谣言传开说他死了，说他在南美洲去世了。这个消息传到了他母亲的耳中，她组织了一场守灵活动，基本上是为了哀悼她的儿子。而在守灵的早晨，他走进了前门，他的母亲看了他一眼，当场就晕倒了。
But anyway, she doesn't die, which is good because he then goes on to compete in the Olympics, Tom. This is your World Cup Olympics
不过不管怎样，他没有死，这很好，因为他后来去参加了奥运会，汤姆。这就是你们的世界杯与奥运会的
crossover. First as a figure skater. Wow. And then in the Romanian bobsleigh team. Blimey. What an absolute hero. Yeah.
跨界。首先作为花样滑冰运动员。哇。然后加入罗马尼亚雪车队。天哪。绝对的英雄。是的。
Well, that's wonderful, Dominic. That's the first of many World Cup miracles. I think we should take a break at this point. When we come back, we will look at the shadow of Mussolini over the World Cup, which is quite a big one, isn't it, Dominic? It is indeed.
好了，这太精彩了，多米尼克。这是众多世界杯奇迹中的第一个。我想我们此时应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看墨索里尼对世界杯的阴影，这阴影相当大，不是吗，多米尼克？确实如此。
We will be back very soon. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我们很快就会回来。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com hello welcome back we are talking the history of the world cup um dominic in the first half we uh we saw the world cup kickoff um uruguay 1930 the next world cup 1934 was held in Italy yeah which by that point of course very much um under the jack boot of Mussolini and the fascists um and Mussolini doesn't really like football does he uh dictators tend not to like football yeah because they can't kind of predict it and control it yeah so I was fascinated to learn that Peron in Argentina I mean, he takes Argentina out from the 1950-1954 World Cups because he just can't control the emotions. But Mussolini takes a punt that he can.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家剧集以及提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。哈喽，欢迎回来，我们正在谈论世界杯的历史。嗯，多米尼克，在上半场，我们看到了世界杯的开幕——1930年的乌拉圭。接下来的1934年世界杯在意大利举行，是啊，当时意大利当然已经在墨索里尼和法西斯分子的铁蹄之下了。墨索里尼其实并不太喜欢足球，对吧？独裁者往往不喜欢足球，是啊，因为他们无法预测和控制足球。是啊，所以我很着迷地了解到阿根廷的庇隆——我的意思是，他在1950年和1954年世界杯时将阿根廷队退赛，因为他根本无法控制这种情绪。但墨索里尼却打赌他可以。
Yes. That Italy will stage a tremendous World Cup and that the national team will actually win. And he's absolutely right. Yeah, Mussolini has an interesting relationship to football. Supposedly, he doesn't like it himself. Part of Mussolini's linguistic nationalism, they call it calcio rather than some derivation of football.
是的。意大利将举办一届极棒的世界杯，并且国家队实际上会赢。他完全正确。是的，墨索里尼与足球有着有趣的关系。据推测，他自己并不喜欢足球。作为墨索里尼语言民族主义的一部分，他们称之为卡尔乔（calcio），而不是足球的其他衍生词。
And he claims that it derives from Siena, doesn't he? The kind of very violent... Yeah, calcio fiorentino. They play this in Florence, and he claims that that derives from a Roman game. Yes, and so his stadium, and again, this tradition that you have to build an enormous grand stadium that proclaims the nature of the country and he says that um uh
他声称这源自锡耶纳，对吧？那种非常暴力的……是的，佛罗伦萨足球（calcio fiorentino）。他们在佛罗伦萨玩这个，他声称这源自古罗马的一场比赛。是的，所以他的体育场——同样，这种必须建造一个宣示国家性质的巨大宏伟体育场的传统——他说，嗯……
it's it's consciously designed to evoke memories of the coliseum and the kind of muscle-bound sub-classical statues of people in football kit and ice hockey pads and all kinds of things it was very very odd if you've ever been so the Mussolini regime had basically been leaning on FIFA as far back as 1930 saying we want the 1934 World Cup Mussolini thinks this would be a tremendous advertisement basically for his regime uh he puts the organization a lot of that is run by this guy called Achille Staracci who is basically he does love football doesn't he does love football, doesn't he? He does like football. He loves sport.
它是有意识地设计用来唤起对斗兽场的记忆，以及那些身穿球衣和冰球护具、各种装备、肌肉发达的半古典式人物雕塑。如果你去过的话，那真是非常非常奇怪。所以墨索里尼政权早在1930年就一直在施压国际足联，说我们想要1934年世界杯。墨索里尼认为这将是他政权的一个极好的广告。他把组织工作交给了阿基尔·斯塔拉奇，这个人基本上——他是真的很喜欢足球，对吧？他是真的很喜欢足球，对吧？他确实喜欢足球。他热爱体育。
So Staracci, people call him the high priest of the cult of Il Duce. His own daughter said he breathed only by the Duce's order. He's absolutely obsessed with sport. He does all things like he jumps through circles of fire, and he jumps on a horse over a car to prove the virility of the sort of... Wouldn't it be brilliant if sports ministers had to do that? Yeah, I'd like to see. Or, you know, exactly.
所以斯塔拉奇，人们称他为主席（Il Duce）崇拜的大祭司。他自己的女儿说他只有在领袖的命令下才能呼吸。他对体育绝对痴迷。他做各种事情，比如跳过火圈，骑着马跳过汽车，以此来证明这种……如果体育部长们必须这样做，那不是太棒了吗？是的，我很想看。或者，你知道，完全如此。
Tracy Crouch. Right, exactly. Colin Moynihan, if you remember him. Well, he'd been a jockey. He was an athlete. He was an Olympic athlete, wasn't he? Was he a jockey? No, he was a cox.
特雷西·克劳奇。没错，完全如此。科林·莫伊尼汉，如果你还记得他的话。好吧，他曾是一名赛马骑师。他是一名运动员。他是一名奥运会运动员，不是吗？他是个赛马骑师吗？不，他是个舵手。
Was he a cox? Yeah, he was a rower. Yes, he was a rower. So whether he could jump through a circle of fire, who knows? However, we've got distracted um so starachi he in some ways creates the iconography of the world cup he produces all these posters well marionetti marionetti does the poster yeah the futurist and also they come up with a massive vulgar cup don't they so so they've got the jewelry made trophy that's which is quite a modest thing yeah and then they because they're
他是舵手吗？是的，他是个赛艇手。是的，他是个赛艇手。所以他是否能跳过火圈，谁知道呢？然而，我们走题了。嗯……所以斯塔拉奇，他在某些方面创造了世界杯的图像学。他制作了所有这些海报——哦，马里内蒂，马里内蒂制作了海报，是的，那个未来主义者。而且他们还设计了一个巨大的、俗气的奖杯，对吧？所以他们制作了镀金奖杯，那是一个相当朴素的东西，是的，然后因为他们是
fascists they have to have a massive huge one so six times the size yes and it's um group of footballers in front of uh in front of the fast jays the um the uh the birching rods of the ancient roman republic but one of the interesting things about this is the countries that tend to to really care about the world cup in the 20th century are new countries, or relatively new countries. And Italy is a good example. Italy has not even existed for a century, when Mussolini wants to host the World Cup. And it's seen as a kind of nationalising project. So Italy, this country where actually people don't even really speak the same language that somebody in Sicily and somebody in Piedmont can't really understand each other. It's really important to show that we can do this. We're a modern country and we're all working in tandem.
法西斯分子，他们必须有一个巨大无比的奖杯，大六倍。是的，它是一群足球运动员站在法西斯标志——古罗马共和国的束棒——的前面。但其中一个有趣的事情是，在20世纪真正关心世界杯的国家都是新国家，或者相对较新的国家。意大利就是一个很好的例子。当墨索里尼想要举办世界杯时，意大利甚至还没有存在满一个世纪。这被视为一种国家化项目。所以意大利这个国家，实际上人们甚至不说同一种语言，西西里人和皮埃蒙特人无法真正互相理解。展示我们能够做到这一点真的很重要。我们是一个现代国家，我们都在齐心协力。
And presumably this is another reason why the British nations are slightly sniffy about it. Because I gather that in 1934, FIFA issued a report naming the world's top football nations. Yeah. Austria, England, and Scotland. Scotland. This was their chance, Tom. issued a report naming the top the world's top football nations yeah uh austria england and scotland scotland this was their chance tom this was their chance and they blew it so the austrians had a very good team and the austrians are the great um pre-second world war world cup champions they kind of get away the vienna cricket club yes the austrians had always really cared about football they had a brilliant team called the wunder Team in the late 1920s and early 1930s.
据推测，这也是英国国家对它略带不屑的另一个原因。因为我了解到，在1934年，国际足联发布了一份报告，列出了世界上顶级的足球国家。是的。奥地利、英格兰和苏格兰。苏格兰。这是他们的机会，汤姆。发布了一份报告，列出了世界上顶级的足球国家，是的，奥地利、英格兰和苏格兰。苏格兰。这是他们的机会，汤姆。这是他们的机会，而他们搞砸了。所以奥地利人有一支非常好的球队，奥地利人是伟大的二战前世界杯冠军。他们有点像是——维也纳板球俱乐部。是的，奥地利人一直非常关心足球。他们在20世纪20年代末和30年代初拥有一支名为“梦之队”的出色球队。
They'd actually, in 1934, they'd only lost one game in the previous three years, I think, and that, of course, was to England in England. Because in those days, whenever anyone came to England, they always lost because of the rain, because of the mud, because of the kind of, you know, the crowd rattling at them or whatever, putting them off.
实际上，在1934年，他们在过去三年里只输了一场比赛，我想，那当然是在英格兰输给英格兰。因为在那些日子里，每当有人来到英格兰，他们总是因为雨水、泥泞、或者你知道的，观众对他们大喊大叫之类的干扰而输球。
The smog. Exactly, the smog. But Austria at them or whatever, putting them off. The smog. Exactly, the smog. But Austria lose to Italy in the semifinals, and then Italy play Czechoslovakia in the final, in Rome, in the Stadio Nazionale, in front of Mussolini. Czechoslovakia has just basically teamed up. They've gone Team Stalin at this point. The story is that it's seen as being fascism against communism. Is that not true?
雾霾。没错，雾霾。但是奥地利——被他们干扰或者别的什么。雾霾。没错，雾霾。但奥地利在半决赛中输给了意大利，然后意大利在罗马的国家体育场（Stadio Nazionale）与捷克斯洛伐克争夺冠军，就在墨索里尼的面前。捷克斯洛伐克当时刚刚结盟。他们此时加入了斯大林战队。有一种说法是，这被视为法西斯主义对抗共产主义。难道这不是真的吗？
It's slightly that I've seen that repeated in quite a lot of football articles and sort of football websites, but it's actually not really true. What had happened was that the French had brokered a putative pact called the Eastern Pact, where all the Eastern European nations plus France would team up with the Soviet Union. This is basically an anti-German pact. And the Czechs had said, yeah, we're well up for this. But actually, it never really comes to fruition. So the idea that it's fascism versus communism, I mean, the Czechs are not communist. However, what is true is that the Second World War was very much on the horizon because Mussolini, in his diary, four days after the World Cup final,
稍微有点这种成分，我看到很多足球文章和某种足球网站都重复过这一点，但实际上并非如此。当时的情况是法国人促成了一个名为“东方公约”的假定条约，即所有东欧国家加上法国将与苏联结盟。这基本上是一个反德条约。捷克人曾说，是的，我们完全赞成。但实际上，它从未真正实现。所以认为这是法西斯主义对阵共产主义的观点——我的意思是，捷克人并不是共产党人。然而，真实的情况是第二次世界大战确实迫在眉睫，因为墨索里尼在他的日记中，在世界杯决赛后四天，
he's going to the Venice Biennale to meet, for the first time, a certain Herr Hitler, who's only been Chancellor of Germany for a year. Who also doesn't like football. Who also doesn't like football, exactly. Just one other thing on the final. Italian defender Luis Monti. Yeah. The only man to play in two World Cup finals for two different countries.
他要去威尼斯双年展首次会见某个希特勒先生，后者担任德国总理才一年。他也讨厌足球。他也讨厌足球，没错。关于决赛还有最后一件事。意大利后卫路易斯·蒙蒂。是的。唯一一个代表两个不同国家参加过两届世界杯决赛的人。
So he played for Argentina. Yes. So that was quite common going right through. Well, actually, there was a guy in 2006, Mauro Comoranese, Argentine born, but plays for Italy. So especially between Italy and Argentina because of immigration into Argentina from Italy, that's very common. Right. especially between italy and argentina because of immigration into argentina from italy that's very common right so 1938 is in paris and all kinds of major um uh football playing nations are not there spain for obvious reasons because it's a civil war austria because it's been
所以他曾为阿根廷效力。是的。所以这贯穿下来是很常见的。事实上，2006年有一个人，毛罗·卡莫拉内西，出生于阿根廷，但为意大利效力。所以特别是在意大利和阿根廷之间，由于向阿根廷的移民潮，这是非常普遍的。没错。特别是在意大利和阿根廷之间，由于向阿根廷的移民潮，这是非常普遍的。没错。所以1938年在巴黎举行，各种主要的足球强国都不在那里：西班牙，因为内战原因显而易见；奥地利，因为它已经被
annexed in the angeles that's right japan too busy invading china. And so because Japan drops out, the Dutch East Indies go in. So that's a colonial team. Yeah. And absolutely my all-time favourite World Cup team because they are captained by a man wearing glasses. They don't do very well to them. They lost 6-0 to Hungary in their opening match, and that was the end of them because it was pure knockout in those days.
吞并（德奥合并），没错；日本，忙着侵略中国。因此，由于日本退赛，荷属东印度群岛得以参赛。所以那是一支殖民球队。是的。绝对是我历来最喜欢的世界杯球队，因为他们的队长是一个戴眼镜的人。他们的战绩不太好。他们在首场比赛中以0比6输给匈牙利，然后就结束了，因为那个年代是纯粹的淘汰赛。
It doesn't matter. I think it's wonderful that a man could wear glasses. So this is where you get politics obviously intervening because it's played in France. The Italians arrive in Marseille and they are booed by the crowds and there are local exiles. Lots of exiles have fled to France from Italy and they sort of encourage people to give the Italian team a hard time. And so Mussolini in the quarterfinal tells them to wear black shirts. Is that right? Well, again, I think that's…
没关系。我觉得一个人能戴眼镜踢球真是太棒了。所以这就是政治明显介入的地方，因为它在法国举行。意大利人抵达马赛时遭到人群的嘘声，那里有很多当地的流亡者。许多流亡者从意大利逃到法国，他们怂恿人们给意大利队难堪。所以在四分之一决赛中，墨索里尼告诉他们穿黑衬衫。是这样吗？嗯，同样，我认为那是……
Again, is this a myth? I think there's an element to it. So there's also a story that they do wear black shirts. I don't know how much this is because of Mussolini's direct influence. So there's also a story, for example, that Mussolini sends them a telegram, win or die. Vincere o marire. Right.
同样，这是一个神话吗？我认为其中有一定的成分。所以也有一个传说，说他们确实穿了黑衬衫。我不知道这在多大程度上是因为墨索里尼的直接影响。所以还有一个传说，例如，墨索里尼给他们发了一封电报：不胜则死（Vincere o morire）。没错。
And this is completely untrue. Apparently, historians have interviewed the players before the players died. And the players said there was no such, you know, there was no such telegram. However,
而这完全是假的。显然，历史学家在球员去世前采访了他们，球员们说根本没有这样的电报。然而，
Dominic, according to top historian of football, Jonathan Wilson, This is your dinner again. I spoke to him at I was dining here. Yeah. And he said that, so Italy get to the semifinals
多米尼克，据顶尖足球历史学家乔纳森·威尔逊所说——这又是你的晚宴。我在那儿吃饭时跟他说过。是的。他说，意大利打进半决赛，
and they're playing Brazil and the Brazilian team, there are wholesale changes to the Brazilian team for no apparent reason. So Leonidas, arguably the Brazil's best player is dropped for the semifinal.
他们对阵巴西，而巴西队为了某种不明原因对阵容进行了大调整。所以可以说是巴西最好球员的莱昂尼达斯在半决赛中被弃用了。
No one knows why. The great thing about Brazil, the number of classically named players. Yeah socrates juvenile brilliant um so it's possible that there's a bit of bribery there and then also there are wholesale changes to the hungarian team which who are brilliant i mean who really should have won um and jonathan suggests that perhaps this was um micklaus horty the dictator well is he dictator as kind of slightly loose isn't he but he's verging on that um trying to keep on side with the fascists so it's possible but then the trouble is with all the so we'll see this
没有人知道为什么。巴西最棒的一点是那些名字富有古典韵味的球员。索格拉特、儒瓦纳尔，太棒了。所以其中可能有点贿赂，然后匈牙利队也发生了重大调整，他们本来很厉害，我的意思是，他们本来真的应该赢的。乔纳森暗示，这也许是米克洛什·霍尔蒂——独裁者？嗯，独裁者这个词有点宽泛，不是吗，但他濒临那种状态——试图讨好法西斯分子。所以这是可能的。但问题是，所有这些——我们将在下一集看到
particularly with our next episode the trouble with all these stories is that that there's there's almost never any documentary evidence for these things. Are you saying that that prevents us from mentioning them? No, no, no, Tom. We've just done some episodes on Alfred and Cakes. No, but it's really interesting how you can tell how these, when you trace them back, how these sort of urban myths about the World Cup, because, of course, there was so little reporting in those days and so little,
特别是所有这些故事的问题在于，对于这些事情几乎从来没有任何历史文件证据。你是说这阻碍了我们提及它们吗？不，不，不，汤姆。我们刚刚做过关于阿尔弗雷德和蛋糕的节目。不，但非常有趣的是，当你追溯时，你会发现关于世界杯的这些都市传说是如何产生的——因为，当然，那个时代的报道太少了，
the matches are not, you know know they're not filmed and preserved so there are urban myths that are then initially told as everybody knows they're slightly apocryphal or they're they're speculative but then they're told and retold and they become sort of established as cast iron fact and we'll see that you know going right into the 1970s with the argentine world cup very controversial um but anyway, yes, Italy do win. I mean, they were a good team. Nobody, not even, you know, I'm sure Jonathan Wilson would have told you, they are a very formidable team.
比赛也没有被拍摄和保存下来，所以有一些都市传说最初被当作“众所周知的事实”来讲述，它们有点杜撰或者带有猜测性，但随后它们被不断讲述，最终被确立为钢铁般的事实。我们将会看到这一点，一直延续到1970年代充满争议的阿根廷世界杯。但不管怎样，是的，意大利确实赢了。我的意思是，他们是一支好球队。没有人，甚至，我确信乔纳森·威尔逊会告诉你，他们是一支非常强大的球队。
They get back home. They're given gold, fascist medals. They meet Mussolini. They're given a big bonus of three months' salary. I mean, actually, it's not as good as if you were a Uruguayan where you get a house, but there you go. And they bring back the jules romeo trophy yeah and they the um the commissioner of the italian football federation then hides it under his bed throughout the second world war there's a slight um quality to the idol of marduk about the jules romeo trophy
他们回到了祖国。他们被授予黄金法西斯勋章。他们会见了墨索里尼。他们获得了相当于三个月薪水的巨额奖金。我的意思是，实际上，这不如乌拉圭人，在那里你可以得到一栋房子，但事实就是如此。他们带回了雷米特杯，是的，他们把——意大利足协的主席在整个第二次世界大战期间把它藏在了他的床底下。马尔杜克偶像的身上有一种轻微的……关于雷米特杯的特质。
people keep the babylonian god who kept being his his statue kept being removed by various other empires it keeps kind of being nicked and stolen reappearing and all kinds of weird things anyway so it doesn't get lost in the in the second world war it stays under there another interesting bit of triv from jonathan um two players there are two players in the world cup who've played in world cups either side of the war there was alfred bickle who was swiss and eric nielsen who was swedish and i think what one of the things that's striking about that is both those countries were neutral i don't know whether it's coincidence or not because if you were a footballer the chances are you'd be very yeah you'd be you'll be involved in that away and we'll see that actually when we get west germany
人们不断地……巴比伦神明，他的雕像不断被各大帝国移走。它不断地被偷走、重新出现，发生各种奇怪的事情。无论如何，所以它在第二次世界大战中没有丢失，一直呆在床底下。来自乔纳森的另一个有趣的冷知识：有两名球员在战争前后的世界杯上都踢过球，一个是瑞士人阿尔弗雷德·比克尔，另一个是瑞典人埃里克·尼尔森。我想其中一个令人震惊的事实是这两个国家都是中立国。我不知道这是否是巧合，因为如果你是一名足球运动员，你很有可能会……是的，你会被卷入那场战斗中。当我们迎来西德时，我们就会看到这一点。
with west germany in the Germany later in the 1950s. But let's just... So had there not been the Second World War, probably the World Cup in 1942 would probably have been held in Brazil or Argentina. And I think most football historians think it would have been won by Argentina or Uruguay. So the Uruguayans had refused,
西德在20世纪50年代后期。但让我们先……所以如果没有第二次世界大战，1942年的世界杯很可能会在巴西或阿根廷举行。我想大多数足球历史学家认为它会被阿根廷或乌拉圭赢得。所以乌拉圭人拒绝了，
having been the great power, they had refused to go to these European World Cups. Yeah, very English behaviour. Because they said not enough people had gone to their world cup and so they would just boycott all these other european ones in protest the war happens um basically it's really interesting there's no great enthusiasm to hold more world cups after the end of the second world war i think there's a slight sense that the World Cup had been a gimmick, that this had been a sort of comical gimmick. And who cared?
作为当年的超级强权，他们拒绝去参加这些欧洲世界杯。是的，非常英国式的行为。因为他们说没有足够的人去他们的世界杯，所以他们为了抗议将抵制所有其他欧洲世界杯。战争爆发了——基本上，非常有趣的是，在二战结束后，人们并没有表现出举办更多世界杯的热情。我认为有一种轻微的感觉，即世界杯一直是一个噱头，这只是一种滑稽的噱头。谁在乎呢？
And also people have got better things to do. I mean, the role played by Mussolini would not show it in a good light. Exactly right. So Japan and Germany have been kicked out of FIFA anyway because of poor behavior. The British countries have, however, rejoined FIFA. And eventually FIFA managed to find somebody who says, well, rejoined FIFA. And eventually, FIFA managed to find somebody who says, well, we'll do the World Cup, and that is Brazil. Now, the Brazilian World
而且人们还有更好的事情要做。我的意思是，墨索里尼所扮演的角色并没有把它描绘成正面形象。完全正确。所以日本和德国无论如何都被国际足联开除了，因为他们表现不佳。然而，英国国家重新加入了国际足联。最终国际足联设法找到一个说“好吧，我们来办世界杯”的人，那就是巴西。现在，巴西世界
Cup, for those of us in England, Tom, held in 1950, is famous for one thing above all. And it pains me to say this, but I suppose we just have to address it england go for the first time now famously i'm going to be heretical now famously people say well typically insular arrogant xenophobic hubristic the english don't prepare properly it's all a shambles the players all complain i think this is actually slightly exaggerated because everybody went in a shambolic way to World Cups in this period. So the English are not unusual in kind of training in a dog field or whatever.
杯，对于我们这些在英格兰的人来说，汤姆，于1950年举行，最因一件事而闻名。这让我感到痛苦，但我猜我们不得不面对它：英格兰队首次参赛。现在众所周知——我要开始异端邪说了——现在众所周知，人们会说：典型的岛国心态、傲慢、仇外、自大，英格兰人没有做好充分准备，一切都是一团糟，球员们都在抱怨。我认为这其实被稍微夸大了，因为在这个时期，所有人去参加世界杯时都是一团糟的。所以英格兰人在狗运动场或类似地方训练并不寻常。
They have three days in Wembley, don't they? Yeah, they actually trained at some, sorry, I said dog field. They trained at a place called Dog Kennel Hill. I don't know what a dog field is. It's not a thing. Anyway, they trained at this place. It was the home of Dog Kennel Hill. I don't know what a dog field is. It's not a thing. Anyway, they traded this place. It was the home of Dulwich Hamlets.
他们在温布利待了三天，对吧？是的，他们实际上在某个——抱歉，我刚才说的是狗运动场。他们在德利山（Dog Kennel Hill）的一个地方训练。我不知道什么是狗运动场。根本没这回事。不管怎样，他们在那个地方训练。那是达利奇哈姆莱特队的训练基地。
Dogs will appear in this story later on. They will. They will. They go on this incredibly long flight. I mean, it's a flight, not a boat. So they go on a flight that stops everywhere. It stops in Dakar. It goes across the Atlantic, and it goes to Rio.
狗稍后会出现在这个故事中。它们会的。它们会的。他们坐上了这架难以置信的长途航班。我的意思是，是一架飞机，而不是船。所以他们坐了一架到处经停的航班。它在达喀尔经停。它飞越大西洋，然后到达里约。
They're too hot, and they don't have the food and all this kind of thing. They beat Chile, and then there's this terrible, terrible, terrible day when they go to Belo Horizonte and they play the United States. 500-1 outsiders. So here's the perfect example of how little we know. When we read that the British, the English rather, they hit the woodwork of the American goal 11 times. They have more than 90% possession.
天气太热，他们没有食物等等诸如此类的事情。他们击败了智利，然后迎来了那个可怕的、可怕的、可怕的日子，他们去了贝洛奥里藏特，对阵美国队。500比1的爆冷局外人。所以这正是我们了解得多么少的一个完美例子。当我们读到英国人——确切地说是英格兰人——11次击中美国队球门的门框时。他们的控球率超过90%。
But how anyone can know these things? I mean, how can you tell? The match isn't filmed and recorded. People aren't noting down, you know, all the statistics of the game. Well, it's all kind of this homeric quality that we've already discussed that one of the reasons why the world cup has this kind of resonance is the opportunity for myths to be generated but so what we do know is that eight minutes before halftime one of the american players they're semi-professionals sort of
但是怎么会有人知道这些事情呢？我的意思是，你怎么能分辨出来？比赛没有被拍摄和记录。人们没有记下比赛的所有统计数据。好吧，这一切都有我们之前已经讨论过的荷马史诗般的特质：世界杯之所以有这种共鸣，原因之一就是它提供了产生神话的机会。但我们确实知道的是，在中场休息前八分钟，其中一个美国球员——他们是半职业球员——
boots the ball vaguely near the english goal he hits this this guy who's from Haiti called Joe Gajans in the face. So this is what some accounts, other people say it was a brilliant header, but it sounds more likely that this ball just hit his head and flew in and flies in past the English goalie. So the Americans lead 1-0. The English attack and attack and attack and can't score.
胡乱把球踢向英格兰球门附近。球击中了一个来自海地、名叫乔·盖詹斯（Joe Gaetjens）的人的脸。所以这是某些人的说法，其他人说这是一个精彩的头球，但听起来更像是这个球正好击中了她的头部，然后飞了进去，从英格兰门将身旁飞过。所以美国人以1比0领先。英格兰人发起了一波又一波的进攻，但就是无法进球。
And amazingly, the Americans have beaten England, the home of football, 1-0. The English attack and attack and attack and can't score. And amazingly, the Americans have beaten England, the home of football, 1-0. And the funny thing is this story, this result, which is a great shock, makes the newspaper headlines everywhere in the world except for two places. That's the United States and England, the two countries
令人难以置信的是，美国人以1比0击败了现代足球的发源地英格兰队。英格兰人发起了一波又一波的进攻，但就是无法进球。令人难以置信的是，美国人以1比0击败了现代足球的发源地英格兰队。有趣的是，这个故事——这个产生巨大震撼的结果——成为了世界上所有地方报纸的头条新闻，除了两个地方。那就是美国和英格兰，这两个
that played. The United States because absolutely nobody cares about it at all. So there's only one American journalist at the 1950 World Cup. He's a man with a fantastically American name of Dent McSkimming. Something from a Martin Amis novel. Exactly. Thomas Pynchon or something. So Dent McSkimming writes for the St. Louis the st louis post dispatch the newspaper who refused
参赛的国家。美国是因为根本没有人关心它。所以1950年世界杯上只有一个美国记者。他是一个有着极其美国化名字的人——登特·麦克斯基明（Dent McSkimming）。像是马丁·阿米斯小说里的角色。完全正确。托马斯·品钦什么的。所以登特·麦克斯基明为《圣路易斯
to pay for him to go so he's he's going on his holiday and paying for it himself uh but nobody really wants to print to print his stories anyway because nobody cares about football and in britain well in britain there's a much much more important sporting story isn't there go for it which is that um this is the day on which England lose for the first time at cricket to the West Indies. Yeah. And this is a much bigger story. Completely eclipses the football.
快报》（St. Louis Post-Dispatch）撰稿，这家报纸拒绝为他支付差旅费，所以他是自费度假去的。但无论如何，没有人真正想刊登他的报道，因为没有人关心足球。而在英国——嗯，在英国有一个更重要得多的体育新闻，对吧？说来听听。那就是英格兰队历史上第一次在板球比赛中输给西印度群岛。是的。这是一个大得多的新闻。完全掩盖了足球的风头。
So British newspapers at the time were much, much smaller than they are today, partly because of austerity, post-war austerity, newsprint restrictions. So there's actually very little sport coverage anyway. And it would simply never have occurred to anybody that this was a story even remotely comparable to the big cricket news no well quite right because at the time you see i think in the time most of most people in britain
所以当时的英国报纸比主要报纸要小得多，部分原因是紧缩政策、战后紧缩政策以及新闻纸限制。所以无论如何，体育报道其实非常少。而且任何人也绝对不会想到这会是一个甚至可以与重大板球新闻相提并论的故事。好吧，完全正确，因为你看，在当时，我认为在当时，英国的大多数人——
i mean as soon as england lose the entire british press corps goes home they're not interested in what happens in the rest of the tournament because i think to them the world cup is is it's completely um it's only with hindsight that this appears like this colossal story yeah because at the time i think to most people in britain this feels like an amusing embarrassment yeah an amusing embarrassment it's like a summer friendly it's a summer friendly tournament i mean it's not a friendly but it feels like a bit of a gimmick so you know oh yeah what a terrible embarrassment but who cares that's but of course but of course for for everyone else who's playing that's not the case and especially brazil and especially for brazil so brazil are really really focused on winning and it's a weird setup isn't it
我的意思是，一旦英格兰输球，整个英国记者团就回家了。他们对剩下的比赛中发生的事情不感兴趣，因为我认为对他们来说，世界杯是完全……只有事后诸葛亮，这看起来才像是一个轰动的故事，是啊，因为在当时，我认为对英国大多数人来说，这感觉像是一次有趣的尴尬，是啊，一次有趣的尴尬，就像一场夏季友谊赛。这是一场夏季友谊赛，我的意思是它不是友谊赛，但感觉有点像个噱头，所以你知道，哦，是的，多么可怕的尴尬，但谁在乎呢，那是……但当然，但当然，对于其他所有参赛的人来说并非如此，尤其是对巴西而言，更是如此。所以巴西人非常非常专注于赢得比赛，这是一个奇怪的阵容，不是吗？
because there isn't really a final it's all done on this this is kind of done on points but essentially what is it the the last match it's Uruguay again our friends and Brazil exactly and what is it Brazil needs to win by two no no Brazil only need to draw Tom oh Uruguay need to win by right two no Uruguay just need to win uh but Brazil if they draw they are the champions so so Brazil okay Brazil who are slight late comcomers, they're behind Uruguay and Argentina. Brazil have been – we'll come back to Brazil and the importance of football in the next podcast. But Brazil have been ruled by this authoritarian modernized group, Getulio Vargas, in the 1930s and the 1940s.
因为实际上并没有决赛，一切都是通过积分来决定的，但本质上是什么呢？最后一场比赛是乌拉圭——我们的朋友们——对阵巴西，完全正确。巴西需要赢两球吗？不，不，巴西只需要打平，汤姆。哦，乌拉圭需要赢两球。不，乌拉圭只需要赢球。但如果巴西打平，他们就是冠军。所以——巴西，嗯，巴西是稍微后来的后来者，他们落后于乌拉圭和阿根廷。巴西一直——我们将在下一期播客中回到巴西及其足球的重要性。但巴西在20世纪30年代和40年代一直由这个独裁的现代化集团、热图利奥·巴尔加斯（Getulio Vargas）统治。
Vargas is a very strange man, Tom. He becomes leader again in Brazil. So he's the sort of dominant person in Brazilian history in the 20th century. But unusually, he committed suicide in office. A very rare thing for a dictator to do. He was depressed that things weren't going so well for him politically.
巴尔加斯是一个非常奇怪的人，汤姆。他再次成为巴西的领导人。所以他是20世纪巴西历史上占主导地位的人物。但不同寻常的是，他在任内自杀身亡。独裁者做出这种事非常罕见。他为事情在政治上进展不顺而感到沮丧。
I suppose Hitler did. Yes, Hitler did. Yeah, I suppose Hitler did. But things weren't going well for him either. But in quite unusual circumstances, it's going to go well for him either but in quite unusual circumstances it's fair to say yes anyway
我想希特勒做过。是的，希特勒做过。是的，我想希特勒做过。但他的事情也进展不顺利。但在很不寻常的情况下，说事情对他的进展顺利也是公平的，是的。无论如何，
so the Brazilian nation they've started to sort of throw themselves into the embrace of football much more keenly very famously in 1938 a Brazilian writer called Gilberto Freire had said that Brazilian football
所以巴西国民开始更加热切地投入到足球的怀抱中。非常著名的是，在1938年，一位名叫吉尔伯托·弗雷雷（Gilberto Freyre）的巴西作家曾说过，巴西足球
was the expression of their mulattoism. That's the expression he used. He said it was basically their own brand of football was a product of their Afro-Brazilian kind of slave heritage. And this would make them superior. They were more physical, all this stuff that now looks a tiny bit dodgy, to be honest. Right. Okay. But so the racial makeup of the Brazilian team,
是他们混血主义的表达。那是他用的词。他说，基本上，他们自己品牌的足球是他们非裔巴西人奴隶制遗产的产物。这将使他们变得更优秀。他们更具身体对抗性，所有这些现在看起来稍微有点可疑的东西，老实说。没错。好吧。但因此，巴西队的种族构成——
there are three black players, aren't there? There are. Yeah. Including the goalkeeper, Barbosa, who is the best goalkeeper in the world at the time. Who is regarded as an excellent goalkeeper. Yeah. The Brazilians are absolutely convinced from the beginning
有三名黑人球员，对吧？是的，确实有。是的。包括门将巴巴萨（Barbosa），他当时是世界上最好的门将。他被认为是一名出色的门将。是的。巴西人从一开始就坚信
they're going to win, just as Uruguay had. Hosts often do well. They'd built this stadium, the Maracanã especially. The Maracanã is this colossal stadium with a capacity of over 160 000 people um it is seen as a symbol of brazilian modernity and national unity it's the first big concrete building in brazil so it anticipates all those buildings in brazilia later in the 1950s kind of modernist absolutely and the news the brazilian newspaper anoint said today brazil has the biggest and most perfect stadium in the 1950s. Yeah, so kind of modernist. Absolutely. And the Brazilian newspaper, Anoite, said,
他们会赢，正如乌拉圭人一样。东道主通常表现不错。他们专门建造了这座马拉卡纳体育场。马拉卡纳是一座宏伟的体育场，容纳人数超过16万。它被视为巴西现代性和国家统一的象征。它是巴西第一座大型混凝土建筑，因此它预示了20世纪50年代后期巴西利亚所有的那些建筑——那种现代主义的风格。绝对是的。巴西报纸《晚报》（Anoite）说，今天巴西拥有世界上最大、最完美的体育场。是啊，那种现代主义的风格。绝对是的。巴西报纸《晚报》说，
today Brazil has the biggest and most perfect stadium in the world, dignifying the competence of its people and its evolution in all branches of human activity.
今天，巴西拥有世界上最大、最完美的体育场，彰显了其人民的能力及其在人类活动各个领域的演变。
And also, Omundo, the day of the final, they have run a picture of the Brazilian team, don't they, with the front page headline, these are the world champions.
而且在决赛当天，他们刊登了一张巴西队的照片，头版标题是：这些就是世界冠军。
And the Uruguayan captain sees it. He buys every copy that he can he takes it up to his teammates and he tells them to urinate on them which i think is brilliant man management so any any captains of sports teams listening to this this is the way forward you're going to do this, Tom. Yes, for England. With the Western male when England play Wales. No, I mean, the Brazilians, I mean, this is, if you want, you were talking about the classical stuff, and the Brazilians all have kind of, they're all called Leonidas.
乌拉圭队长看到了。他买下了所有能买到的复印件，拿给他的队友看，并让他们在上面撒尿——我认为这是绝佳的管理艺术。所以任何收听节目的体育队队长，这就是前进的方向。你会这么做的，汤姆。是的，为了英格兰。在英格兰对阵威尔士时，和西方的男性一起。不，我的意思是，巴西人——我的意思是，如果你想说的话，你刚才谈到了古典的东西，巴西人都有点——他们都叫莱昂尼达斯。
I mean, this is the great 20th century object lesson hubris because the Brazilians have composed a samba ready to go called Brazil the victors the mayor of Rio actually congratulates the team on becoming world champions before the final even happens you players who in less than a few hours will be hailed as champions by millions of compatriots you who have no rivals in the entire hemisphere You who will overcome any other competitor. You who I already salute as victors. So everybody's massively overexcited. 200,000 people cram into this stadium with a capacity of 160,000. People have already died in stampedes for tickets.
我的意思是，这是20世纪关于狂妄自大的伟大教训，因为巴西人已经创作了一首准备就绪的桑巴舞曲，名为《巴西，胜利者》。里约市长甚至在决赛开始前就祝贺球队成为世界冠军：“你们这些在短短几个小时内将被数百万同胞欢呼为冠军的球员，你们在整个半球没有对手，你们将战胜任何其他竞争者，我在此向你们致敬，向胜利者致敬。”所以每个人都极度兴奋。20万人挤进这座容量为16万的体育场。人们已经在抢票的踩踏事件中丧生了。
There's such enthusiasm. And what's worse, Tom, Brazil actually went 1-0 up in a match they only needed to draw and then you know even if you know nothing about football from the way we've been telling this story you know what's gonna happen you know what's gonna happen you require score two goals and win the match 2-1 there's such shock in brazil the doctors at the stadium had to treat 169 people for hysteria. So I was reading about it.
热情如此高涨。更糟糕的是，汤姆，巴西队在一场只需要打平的比赛中竟然以1比0领先，然后你知道的，即使你对足球一无所知，从我们的讲述中你也知道接下来会发生什么。你知道会发生什么，乌拉圭连进两球，以2比1赢得比赛。巴西国内震惊不已，体育场的医生不得不为169人治疗癔症（歇斯底里症）。我当时正在读相关报道。
And over the years that followed, Brazilian sports writers compared this defeat to the murder of JFK, the Titanic, and Hiroshima. Oh, wow. So any British listeners, we're not the only people who indulge in massive sporting hyperbole. But the saddest story is the one about Barbosa, isn't it? The goalkeeper who lets the goal in. And it's the three black players in particular who are the particular objects of Brazilian fury. The press, the Brazilian newspapers say they're cowards. They don't have discipline.
在随后的几年里，巴西体育记者将这次失利与肯尼迪遇刺、泰坦尼克号和广岛相提并论。哦，哇。所以任何英国听众，我们并不是唯一沉迷于巨大体育夸张的人。但最悲伤的故事是关于巴巴萨的，对吧？那个丢球的门将。尤其是这三名黑人球员，成为了巴西人愤怒的主要对象。媒体和巴西报纸说他们是懦夫。他们没有纪律。
They don't have the discipline of their white compatriots, all this sort of stuff. I mean, Barbosa in particular, he would later in life tell a story about going into a bar and sort of semi-deserted bar and hearing a woman turn to her little boy and say, look, that's the man who made all Brazil cry. And he comes to be seen as a kind of, as a Jonah. Yeah. they'll cry and he he comes to be seen as a kind of as a jonah yeah um he he it's it's thought that he'll bring bad luck to any team that he um that he plays for and he comes to believe it himself
他们没有同胞那样的纪律，诸如此类的话。我的意思是，巴巴萨尤其如此，他后来在生活中讲述了一个故事：他走进一家半荒废的酒吧，听到一个妇女转头对她的小男孩说：“看，那就是让整个巴西哭泣的人。”他被视为一种灾星。是的。
and so there's this story isn't there that he gets the groundsman to smuggle the goal posts out yeah you know the goals posts through which the the two goals have been scored by Uruguay. And he takes these goalposts and he sets them on fire and he has a barbecue and he invites his friends to come and eat the meat that has been grilled on the burning embers of these goalposts to try and expiate the curse. But it doesn't do him any good, Tom, because even as late as 1994,
他们会哭泣，他被视为一种灾星。是的。嗯……人们认为他会给自己效力的任何球队带来厄运，他自己也开始相信这一点。
a World Cup Brazil won in the United States, he went to the training camp for the Brazilian team, and he was turned away because he was a curse. So the most famous story about the aftermath of 1950, there's a boy in a place called Baru,
所以有一个传说是这样的，他让场地管理员把球门柱偷偷运出来——你知道的，乌拉圭人攻入两球的那些球门柱。他把这些球门柱拿走并点燃，举行了一场烧烤，邀请他的朋友们来吃用这些燃烧的球门柱余烬烤出来的肉，试图以此消除诅咒。但这对他毫无帮助，汤姆，因为即使到了1994年，
which is in Sao Paulo State, very poor, who's 10 years old, who is with his father. And he says it's the only time in his life he ever saw his father cry. And the boy says later, there was a sadness so great, so profound that it felt like the end of a war with Brazil, the loser and many people dead. And Dominic, who was that little boy?
巴西在美国赢得世界杯时，他去了巴西队的训练营，却被拒之门部门外，因为他是个厄运。因此，关于1950年世界杯后遗症最著名的故事是：在圣保罗州一个非常穷的地方，一个叫巴鲁（Baru）的地方，有一个10岁的小男孩和他的父亲在一起。他说这是他一生中唯一一次看到父亲哭泣。小男孩后来回忆说，当时有一种极其巨大、深沉的悲伤，感觉就像一场战争的结束，巴西是失败者，许多人丧生。多米尼克，那个小男孩是谁？
So that little boy was somebody called Edson Arantes de Nascimento, better known as Pele. Dun, dun, dun. On that note, Tom, we should,
那个小男孩就是埃德松·阿兰特斯·多·纳西门托，也就是我们更熟悉的贝利。咚，咚，咚。基于这一点，汤姆，我们应该
blow the whistle. We should blow the whistle. This is only half time though. No, it's, it's, it's the, it's the quarterfinal.
吹响终场哨。我们应该吹响终场哨。不过这只是中场休息。不，这是，这是四分之一决赛。
We've got the semifinal tomorrow, and then we have the final on Wednesday. So tomorrow we will be returning with the history, the extraordinary political history of the World Cup in the 1950s, 60s, 70s.
我们明天有半决赛，然后我们在周三有决赛。所以明天我们将带着历史回归，即20世纪50年代、60年代、70年代世界杯非凡的政治历史。
Then we will reach a climax with a very special guest, the former England captain Gary Lineker will be talking us through what's happened to football and to the World Cup
然后我们将迎来高潮，邀请一位非常特别的嘉宾，前英格兰队队长加里·莱因克尔将向我们讲解从20世纪80年代开始，足球和世界杯发生了什么，他自己的回忆以及其中的影响。他是一个对媒体、对世界杯的政治角色思考得相当多的人，对吧，汤姆？但随后我们将进入我们的32支球队马拉松，我们将在其中挑选所有参赛者故事中的历史面向。
from the 1980s onwards, his own memories and the implications. He's somebody who thinks quite a lot, isn't he, Tom, about the media, about the political role of the World Cup. But then we will be getting into our 32-team marathon where we'll be selecting aspects of history from the stories of all the competitors.
在卡塔尔。在卡塔尔。所以这里面应有尽有，从罗马皇帝、腓尼基女王，到20世纪70年代的城市游击队、抗议运动、皇帝、韩国人——韩国的……加拉帕戈斯群岛上的鬣蜥，范围太广了。我想强调的是，我假设如果你听到了这里，你对足球有一定程度的兴趣。但如果你没有，请放心，这次马拉松里绝对没有足球。这是一场世界历史的节日，汤姆，一部全球历史的节日。全球历史的节日正是如此，多米尼克。
At Qatar. At Qatar. So that's everything from roman emperors and phoenician queens to 1970s urban guerrillas protest movements emperors south korean south korean uh iguanas on the galapagos Islands, so much range. And just to emphasise, I am assuming that if you've listened this far, you have a moderate degree of interest in football. But if you don't, please be reassured there is absolutely no football in this marathon. It is a festival of world history, Tom, of global history. A festival of global history is exactly what it is, Dominic.
在卡塔尔。在卡塔尔。所以内容包罗万象，从罗马皇帝、腓尼基女王，到20世纪70年代的城市游击队抗议运动、南韩的南韩的、呃，加拉帕戈斯群岛上的鬣蜥，跨度非常大。顺便强调一下，我假设能听到这里的听众，对足球都有一定程度的兴趣。但如果没有的话，请放心，这场马拉松里绝对没有足球。这是一场世界历史的盛宴，汤姆，一场全球历史的盛宴。这正是一场全球历史的盛宴，多米尼克。
So non-stop fun. So we will see you tomorrow. We've got England winning the World Cup. We've got World Cup in Argentina. Germans behaving badly. But also very well. Germans behaving well and badly. Yes.
所以精彩不断。明天见。我们预测英格兰赢得世界杯，阿根廷世界杯，德国人的糟糕表现，但也表现得很好。德国人表现得好又坏。是的。
So we will see you tomorrow. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's rest isistorypod.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那我们明天见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余》，想要获取独家播客、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册，也就是 restishistorypod.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。